- It's dessert time.
(upbeat music)
I'm James Briscione,
Director of Culinary Research
here at the Institute
of Culinary Education.
Today, we're taking your
candy aisle favorites
and making a gourmet dessert.
Let's do this.
First thing we're gonna
do is take some candy,
cookies and ice cream and transform them
into a beautiful tart.
We're gonna start here just
with a bit of vanilla ice cream.
Had that out to soften up a little bit.
Might be a little runny,
but that's alright.
Don't worry about it.
And we're just gonna take
that, mix that that up.
It's very soft, but we should be OK.
We're gonna throw a little bit
of candy and cookie into there.
We're gonna take some of our cookies here,
chop them up, throw them right in.
Some of the Reese's Pieces,
my personal favorite,
chop them up a little bit
and they're going to get mixed in here
with a bit of vanilla ice cream.
Get all that good stuff in there.
If I were sitting at home,
no one else watching,
I'd be on the couch with this bowl.
Done.
But, we're gonna do this up.
More cookies here.
They're just gonna make
the base of our tart.
None of these super fine,
they're kind of light,
they have a little bit more texture,
you get some of those creamy bits,
you get some of the cookie bits.
And we're just gonna take those
and spread them in to the
base of our little molds here.
So we're set with that.
Then I'm just gonna
spoon that ice cream mix
right over the top to settle in
all those little nooks and crannies.
And then just level the top,
then here's where you can have some fun.
We're gonna take these candies
and just start lining
them up across the top,
you can make any kind of
pattern or shape you want.
May have gotten myself in
trouble with this idea.
I was thinking monochromatic
but it was gonna be way too
long to pick through all those.
You can do this with any type
of candy, you could use M&Ms,
now if you wanted to go Skittles
for a little more color you could,
but these ones with a nice
crisp shell like this,
tend to do the best.
OK, I made it.
We're gonna take these off to the freezer.
Let them set up.
And we'll get back to it.
Every great dessert needs a sauce.
So we did here is we took a
little bit of heavy cream,
some bourbon and strawberry fruit roll ups
and just simmered those down
so it was a nice thick creamy sauce.
You kind of get a
strawberries and cream thing
with a little kick of bourbon.
I'm from the South,
I love to throw a little
bit of bourbon in there.
But look you don't have to have it at all.
Just your fruit roll up
and a little bit of cream
and you have a beautiful sauce.
So we're gonna take a bit of that sauce,
drop it right here on the plate.
Get all the extra off the spoon
and then give it a little.
Perfectly sloppy.
So that sets the frame for our plate.
We're gonna come back
to that ice cream tart out of the freezer.
I'm just gonna run this around.
Lift it up, set it down right there.
Looks fantastic, you've
got all those Oreo cookies
on the bottom.
That's actually beautiful
exactly as it is.
But we can do better.
I'm gonna take some fresh strawberries
and just kind of arrange them
around the edge coming down one side.
We've got our Twinkies.
Tear it up into some little chunks,
kind of tuck it in there
with the strawberries.
You've got a like a little
strawberry short cake
thing happening.
Get that in there.
Looking good.
Bring it home with our mint.
Just a couple nice fresh
leaves right in there.
And there is it.
Gourmet dessert out of the candy aisle.
You guys may think it's junk food,
but you can have a lot of fun with this.
Put your own spin on it.
Plate it up beautiful,
let's see what you got.